do you feel like you get enough credit
though not yet it's coming though every
every i feel like every artist go
through this [ __ ] you know i'm saying
like
even the drake's even you know saying
everybody went through that period of
time where all this [ __ ] been future he
went through it you should definitely
went through it it was it was one point
is this tweet i'm trying to find to this
day
the future had tweeted he was like man
they [ __ ] keep playing with me
like i ain't dropping him you know they
just pop in this [ __ ]
and i think like a year later that's
when future
you know you know it's crazy you say
that about him because i remember having
that conversation because future put out
tony montana yeah and magic he's going
crazy yeah but like people really
weren't paying attention until he went
on that mixtape run exactly he put pluto
out no one really cares exactly you know
what i'm saying like he has the high one
record no one cares like exactly so i be
like that you know what i'm saying you
gotta just you gotta know where you at
as an artist know where you wanna be
mentally you know what i'm saying and
keep putting that work in until and [ __ ]
crack